[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this talk entitled
what's wrong with the left
subtitles and how to fix it my starting
point is that
the uk lift
is not in a good shape
it's in a better shape than it's been
for a long time
and that's great
but
labor today should be 20 or 30 points
ahead in the polls
not level pegging with the tories
um
in the recent local elections labor
sadly and i emphasized sadly and
regretfully
failed to make many of the predicted
gains
that it had hoped for
so my question is
how can we turn around
labour's fortunes and the fortunes of
the left and wider progressive movement
how can we ensure that
we
move forward
in a way that makes the left stronger
more effective accessible and popular
now hand on heart
i have to say i don't have all the
answers
um i've got no magic wand no panacea
but what i want to do is share with you
today
some ideas
which you may or may not agree with and
you might have better ideas and i hope
you'll put them forward
during the q a
so i've got several ideas i want to talk
about
the first is
for the left to be successful
it needs to be constructive
positive
and optimistic
i'm sad to say that so often the left is
negative and oppositionist
the left is against the tories against
nhs privatization against trident
nuclear missiles against austerity
against corporate power and abuses
and quite rightly
but what is the left for
i think
often not always but off on the left is
very weak on what its alternatives are
going to be
and when we want to win public support
they probably want to know
well if you don't agree with this
what are you going to do instead
so
[Music]
knowing exactly what
a left government would do
is a very important part of the equation
of winning public support
i was at a debate yesterday on
universal basic income
and one of the speakers the main
advocate was guy standing who i admire
greatly and totally support his
arguments in favor of a universal basic
income
but i pressed him not once but three
times
what will be the level of this universal
basic income how much per week per adult
and how much will it cost for the whole
of the nation
and how will it be funded
and he wouldn't answer
now i respect his decision not to answer
but i thought
how can you convince the public if you
can't tell us
what level the universal basic income
will be set at
how much will cost the government and
how it's going to be paid for
people want to know those answers and to
be a credible alternative
you've got to have those answers
when it comes to austerity
quite rightly the left has been highly
critical and oppositionist to austerity
but i have very rarely ever seen any
left person
explain
how a left government
would
overcome the deficit
and fund the public services we rightly
vitally need
you know simply opposing austerity is
not good enough the public want to know
how you're going to plug the deficit how
are you going to fund these services
and i won't go into it now but
i worked out
a clear funding package
totaling 1 000 billion pounds
by which we could not only plug the
deficit and ensure it didn't recur
but also pay off a large proportion
of the national debt
and when i've spoken about this to
audiences even very skeptical audiences
perhaps not everyone's totally agreed
but at least they've said you're the
first person i've ever heard spell out
how we can get out of this mess and
avoid the nightmare of austerity
the second point i'd make is that
the left needs to embrace
progressive collaboration
unite the many to defeat the few
isolate the main enemy
the tories
build a grand alliance against the
conservatives
from the center
to the left
embracing
labor
the lib dems the greens applied kumaru
the snp
and perhaps even the sdlp and sinfain
for the sake of
winning
we have to sometimes be prepared to sink
our differences to work with others who
we may not entirely
or much agree with
but for the sake of the bigger cause
we have to be prepared to work with
others
um
there is a mentality a lot of the left
that
we are the only progressives that all
these other people they're they're
they're they're they've got they're
wrong
we're the ones who are right and they
have to follow us
that is arrogant
and sectarian
now
part of the answer in terms of
building this progressive alliance is of
course to
embrace proportional representation
which
labor still at the moment will not
support
in 2005 to give an example
the last
time labour won
an election
um labor got 35 percent of the votes
but won 55 of the seats
that is not democracy
that is not what the charters and
suffragettes fought for
in the 2015 election the conservatives
won
37 percent of the vote
but 51 of the seats
again a clear disjunction between the
level of popular support
and the
number of seats won in parliament and
the ability to form a government
what is truly shocking
is that in britain
no governing party has won a majority of
votes since 1931
every single government
has one power based on minority support
even thatcher's landslide in 1983
and blair's landslide in 1997
were based on about 42 or 43
of the vote
that
is not democracy
and it breaks my heart
that labor seems content
with this flawed and frankly corrupt
electoral system whereby millions of
votes don't count and we keep on getting
parties with minority support in power
if we'd had proportional representation
say in the 1970s
we would have never ever had the
thatcher government
never had the thatcher government or the
major government
so
to me
collaboration from the center to the
left is absolutely fundamental
in powering forward a progressive
government in this country
in addition
collaboration
to keep out the tories
also means a progressive alliance of
anti-tory parties
where all those who oppose the tories
work together and collaborate with
electoral deals to win
at least key marginal constituencies
now
as you recall
in the recent local elections in london
in the borough of richmond
the lib dems and the greens worked
together on a progressive alliance
labor refused but the lib dems and
greens ousted the tories
they would never ever would have done
that if they hadn't worked together
so the greens stood down for the lib
dems the lib dem stood down for the
greens
and they wiped the tories out
it shows that a progressive alliance
really can make a difference
nationally
a progressive alliance
similar to the one done in richmond
could probably oust
between 30 and 60 conservative mps
that could make the difference between
forming or not forming the next
government
[Applause]